it's a July morning on a beach in Europe
the last day of your holidays you use
your mobile phone to send a text message
and then close your eyes your words are
picked up by local telephone lines and
transmitted from one network to another
until they reach the country where your
boyfriend lives this is called roaming
telephone companies generally charge too
much for this service which resulted in
unpleasant surprises at the end of the
holidays but roaming prices have now
dropped dramatically thanks to the
European Commission the Commission is a
group of politicians men and women who
meet every Wednesday in Brussels
we call them commissioners together they
form the government of Europe so to
speak they all have their own specific
field of responsibilities and come from
different countries it is their role to
defend the general interest of the
European Union when they take their
oaths they swear not to accept
instructions from their own government
each Commissioner expresses an opinion
on all subjects and contributes to all
decisions it is often said that the
Commission is the driving force of the
European Union its main role is to take
the initiative in proposing EU
legislation for instance the College of
Commissioners was the first to conceive
of the possibility of reducing roaming
tariffs in Europe this proposal was then
examined and adopted by the other
European institutions you benefit from
that initiative a few years later lying
on your deck chair to end your holidays
you stroll along the water's edge for a
while you still do not know it but it is
the European Commission which makes sure
that the water lapping at your feet is
not polluted the quality of bathing
water is enshrined in EU law and if the
Member States refused to take the
necessary measures to ensure the
cleanliness of their Shore the
Commission may penalize them in its role
as guardian of the treaties a few hours
later you arrive at the railway station
you will very soon be with your
boyfriend and once again strange as it
may sound this is partly thanks to the
European Commission its third major task
is to manage the policies and budget of
the EU for example
assistance for the regions and their
infrastructures the Commission is
responsible for organizing the European
financial support granted for example to
airport motorway and railway projects in
Europe without it the train taking you
at 300 kilometers to your boyfriend
would probably not yet have been built
halfway through your journey you go to
the buffet car to drink an espresso
while you watch the Sun blinking behind
the line of trees before it warmed your
hands the coffee which you're enjoying
grew far away from here on the plateau
of an African country and it reached
this railway carriage partly thanks to
the Commission the Commission is
responsible for performing tasks on
behalf of the European Union outside its
borders in practice this involves
negotiating commercial treaties with
foreign countries on the basis of a
mandate entrusted to it by the Member
States and also establishing development
programs in emerging countries in Africa
these programs help to develop coffee
exports for example right of initiative
guardian of the treaties policy
implementation and international
dimension in one day from the beach to
the arms of your boyfriend the work of
the European Commission has made your
reunion easier